the desperate calls of a mother
to her missing child
it's august 2019 and search
teams are scouring this jungle for
teenager nora quarren
who's vanished from a malaysian eco
resort
[Applause]
after 10 days her body is found
today a coroner ruled this 15 year old's
death
was likely due to misadventure not
murder
i ruled that there was no one involved
in the death of nora and it is no
it is more probable than not that she
died by misadventure i.e she had gone
out of the soraa house on her own and
subsequently got lost in the abandoned
palm oil plantation
nora suffered from learning and physical
disabilities which her family say
made her incapable of climbing out of a
window
or walking alone into the jungle utterly
disappointed by today's ruling
they've repeatedly stated they believe
she was abducted i have a number of
very precise reasons to believe that my
daughter was kidnapped
how or why i'm not qualified to say
10 a.m on the 3rd of august the quarrens
landed in kuala lumpur
and took a taxi for around an hour to
the dussen resort
at five o'clock they went for a walk
around the grounds
by 10 that night they were all in bed
but around eight the following morning
sebastian woke the children
to find nora was missing he said words
to the effect of nora's not
here you know can you see her and
i um immediately immediately
panicked
the alarm was quickly raised and in the
coming days
hundreds of people joined the search
hunting through dense undergrowth
with specialist teams looking on the
ground and in the air
nine days after nora was last seen her
family offered a reward
for information nora is our
first child she has been vulnerable
since the day she was born
she is so precious to us and our hearts
are breaking
the next day magendran walked this path
with volunteers
he was with them when they found nora's
body near a waterfall
around a mile and a half from
nora died of internal bleeding due to
stress and starvation
there was no evidence of sex assault but
it couldn't be
totally ruled out her parents wanted an
open verdict saying evidence including
an open window
unidentified prince at the scene and her
lack of injuries
means she may have been kidnapped the
family was staying here
at the soraa house lawyers for the hotel
though
disagree there was no evidence to
suggest any foul play
or any third party intervention in
respect
of the case so specifically there was no
reason for the police to even
suspect or investigate an adduction
angle
to this particular issue what happened
to this vulnerable teenager
remains a mystery nora quarren
disappeared and died here the jungle
may never reveal its secrets to her
family
siobhan robbins sky news